what if all the ice in the world acted  like this  this is sodium acetate also known as hot  ice it's the same thing that's used in  chemical heating packs and can make  these cool ice crystal formations  so although it's not technically ice it  does look like it but it's also hot to  the touch  so  what would happen if we replaced our ice  with it well the first thing you'd  notice would be that all the animals  living in the arctic would migrate down  south  this is because the arctic would become  extremely hot and all the new hot ice in  it would burn anyone who touched it but  what if all this hot ice suddenly melts  well then all the chemicals from the hot  ice would go into our oceans and make  them toxic you wouldn't want to drink or  eat any of this stuff either if you  consumed enough of it you'd get sick and  die  so although this could make it possible  to snowboard in your bathing suit it  wouldn't be worth it